Mà chấp anh chung đảng khoảng 18,000 đặt thông nhất của tổ lâm tổng vĩ thư bàn chấp anh chung đảng khoảng 18,
tiếp tục giữ trách tổng vĩ thư bàn chấp anh chung đảng khoảng 18,
đồng chỉ trận thành bánh quý viên một chính trị trụ tịch Quốc hội thay mặt gần trụ tệ báo cáo kết quả tổng vĩ chính trị
gồm mời chính đồng trị. Một tổ lâm tổng vĩ thư bàn chấp anh chung đảng khoảng 18,
lý thư quả tổng vĩ trụ gần. Thay trận thành bánh quý viên một chính trị khoảng 18,
lý thư đồng vĩ thư bàn phục hội trụ tịch Quốc hội khoảng 18,
bàn chân tổng vĩ viên một chính trị khoảng 18, thường trực bàn vĩ thư
lý thư đảng uì các cơ quan đảng trụ gần. Mốn lê mình hâng quý viên một chính trị
khoảng 18, lý thư trụ gần bàn chân bàn tổng vân. Năm gỗ văn chiến
vên một chính trị khoảng 18, phó vi thư thường trực đảng uì Quốc hội phó chủ tịch thường trực Quốc hội.
Sao buổi thị mấy ngoài, huy vên một chính trị khoảng 18, lý thư trụ gần đảng
vĩ thư đảng uì mặt chạp tổng quốc các loàn thể trung gần. Chủ tịch
huy bàn trụ gần mặt chạp tổng quốc Việt Nam. Mày phần bàn rằng
huy vên một chính trị khoảng 18, huy vên bàn trường bụ đảng uì chính phủ.
Phó vi thư côn huy Trung gần đại thưởng bộ trường bộ phó phẩm. Tảm
vương tâm quan, huy vên bộ chính trị khoảng 18, huy vên ban thường vụ đảng
huy chính phủ. Nữ đảng huy côn gần đại thưởng bộ trường bộ côn gần.
Chính, huy vên vụ chính trị khoảng 18, lý thư thành huy hà nội.
Mày, huy vên trọng giữa, huy vên bộ chính trị khoảng 18, lý thư
trường bộ chính trị khoảng 18, huy vên ban thường vụ côn huy Trung gần
đại thưởng trụ nhẹp tổng quốc chính trị khôn độ gần dân dân dân dân dân dân dân
đưa các bạn biểu khách quý thư thần thè đã biểu ở đại hội.
Tây mạch mạch mạch mạch phayn Trung guân khoảng 15, huy vên
vừa đại hội bầu, tôi xin bây tỏ lòng viên sâu sắc trước sự
phía dấm và tiếng nghiệm mạ đại hội. Lại hội giành cho chúng tôi
tây là vinc dựa vời chắc nghiệp lớn trước bạn trước khiến dân
chúng tôi sẽ ng Veterch phép mừng
tạm tạm tạm quan lực để phụ pụ xin nghiệp cao cán của đạm của kích mạch.
Vì nhân dân trước tạm thè đã hội
Màn chấp hành Trung Quốc quanh Mui Won,
quên truyệt lối Trung thành với một tiêu đi tưởng của đáng,
đặt lời y quốc gia sân tập lên trên hết trước hết,
giữ vương độc lập tự chủ,
kênh quết bảo vệ,
tổ quốc bảo vệ, nhưng ra,
Màn chấp hành Trung Quốc quanh Mui Won sẽ làm vẻ bằng tinh thần
nếu cơ tăng nhất,
nói đi đối với làm, làm đến công,
làm vẻ cuy zân, phải làm ngang, làm đúng,
làm tốt, phải mong măng lực lính đạc và tổ chức thử hẹt,
hếu quản phục nhanh zân là thức đong măng lực lính đạc,
vì tiến và zanh dự tình đồng trí,
vì vinh Trung đạc, khoá mấy quân,
quan chấp hành Trung Quốc mạng khoá mấy quân,
tiếp tục, kênh chia sê dựng dựng đạc trong sách vấn mạnh,
giữ dín sự gọi mặt kết thông nhất trong đạc,
tăng cường kỳ lật của đáng, kỳ cơm pháp nước,
quan thiệp cơ chế kệm xác quỳ lật,
kinh quyết phòng chống tham yếu ngon lăng vý têu cực,
thật kiện hành tiếp kiệp,
chống phố chưa hình thức làm tốt công tác cám bộ đặt đúng người,
rao đúng việc đến giá bằng sản phẩm,
tói bằng quy tín trong gia dân trong giúp người có đức,
hóa tài, gảm làm biết làm,
làm được việc,
đưa các khỏi hệ thống yếu người cơ hội,
ngay chánh chức nhẹm mối phòng tý đối với làm,
kinh quyết chúng tư cực.
Măng chấp hành Trung Quốc khoá mấy quân,
bây tỏ lòng chiến sâu sách đối với các đồng chi,
quyết viên Trung Quốc,
khoá mấy mà không tái cơ,
nhất là cơ đồng chi lấy đạo chủ trốt,
các đồng chi quyết viên bộ xin trị,
quyết viên bà biết thơ,
các đồng chi đã công viên chỉ tòi tâm nghiệp mà gling,
cũng có đoàn kết phùn đặc nềm tin,
lấy đạo toàn đàn toàn dân toàn cốt ta,
hoàn thành tháng lợi, nghĩ quyết đại hội.
Mấy mà của đàn,
chúng tòi mong cơ đồng chi tiếp tục quan tâm,
bói thẳng thẳng xây dự tipped tục trên kinh nghiệp cho tế kế cận,
tiếp tục trung sức,
vì sự nghiệp cách mạnh của đàn và của nhớ dân,
sự đồng hành của các đồng chi,
là ngon cổ vũ tinh thẳng tò lấn,
nè măn chắc phải nhu hơn đại hổng mùi bốn,
khoan thành nhiệm bộ trong hiểm kiếm mới,
giữa các đồng chi,
chẳng đường phí trước,
có nhiều việc lấn,
đoài hỏi quyết tâm càng,
giữa tiêm,
lũ lực không ngừng,
một lần nữa,
thấy mặt măn chắc phải nhu chung ngừng khoan mùi bốn,
xin chân chẳng cảm mơn,
đại biểu đại hội,
đoàn làm việc tâm tâm cí tòi chắc nhẹn,
cảm ơn các đồng chi đàn quyền,
đồng bào,
xin xí cạnh ngược,
kêu bào tả nước ngoài,
và mạnh mẽ khu tế,
đoàn luôn ngứng về đại hội,
dành cho đàn tình cảm và sự uống hộ.
chức đàn,
chức nhân dân,
chức đồng chi đại biểu,
giữa đại hội,
chúng tôi trăm kết,
sẽ đoàn kết một lòng,
làm việc nghiêm tục,
hình động quyết liệt,
nếu lực tiến công,
để xứng đáng phuy nhiệm tiêm của đàn,
của nhân dân,
của các đại biểu đại hội,
đoàn xanh cho chúng tôi,
quyết tâm lấy đạo,
thực hiện tháng lời hình quyết đại hội đại biểu,
toàn khúc lần tính mối ốn của đàn,
đưa đất nước phát triển hung cơ hình thích vợ,
trong kỉ quyền mối,
xí p trân trọng cảm ơn các đồng chi.